F
AMERICAN DOLLARS SPENT IN THE
UKRAINE WILL CHANGE THAT.
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS TENNESSEE
SENATOR BILL HAGGERTY, WHO
SERVED ON A SENATE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE.
YOU HEARD MY CONVERSATION
EARLIER WITH PETER DOOCY.
WE ARE STILL BUYING AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF ENERGY FROM RUSSIA.
RUSSIA IS ATTACKING UKRAINE, AND
CONGRESS IS GOING TO BE ASKED TO
SPEND THE $64 BILLION THAT WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PRINT OR
BORROW TO SEND IT TO UKRAINE.
WE ARE PAYING EVERY WHICH WAY IN
THIS SITUATION.
>> MY REACTION IS VERY SIMPLE.
YOUR DISCUSSION WITH PETER
UNDERSCORED THAT WE ARE FUNDING
THE WAR MACHINE THAT PUTIN IS
UNLEASHING ON UKRAINE.
THINK ABOUT THE SHORTSIGHTED
GREEN POLICIES THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION -- TO WAGE WAR ON
THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY HERE.
THAT HAS COME STRAIGHT TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN, AND HERE WE ARE,
CONTINUING TO DEFY THESE
ACTIVITIES.
PUTIN HAS BUILT UP A WAR CHEST.
THIS IS WHERE THESE POLICIES
HAVE LED TO US.
>> RIGHT NOW, SENATOR, GIVEN THE
FACT THAT RUSSIAN TROOPS HAVE
ENCIRCLED THE CAPITAL OF KYIV,
THEY ARE POISED TO BRING IN A
LOT MORE TROOPS IF NECESSARY.
WHAT IS BIDEN GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT?
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE NOW, BUT
IT'S NOT LIKE WE ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PUSH RUSSIA OUT, AS LONG
AS CHINA, WHICH YOU HAVE BEEN
TERRIFIC ON THE CHINA
QUESTION -- AS LONG AS CHINA IS
GETTING ANOTHER CUSHION TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> WHAT WE'VE DONE IS PUSH
RUSSIA CLOSER TO SHINE DOMINIC
CHINA.
PUT IN A SCENE THE WEAKNESS OF
THE BAI DEMONSTRATION AS --
NOTHING WORSE THAN WHEN THINGS
RATCHET UP AGAINST US AROUND THE
WORLD.
CHINA IS WATCHING US CLOSELY.
CHINA AND RUSSIA HAVE BEEN EVEN
CLOSER THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
THIS ENGAGEMENT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE CCP
MUST BE THINKING, THEY ARE
EYEING TAIWAN VERY CLOSELY, WANT
TO SEE WHAT THE WORLD'S REACTION
IS GOING TO BE.
NOT WORKING OUT WELL FOR THE
REST OF THE WORLD, NOT FOR
TAIWAN.
STRATEGICALLY, OUR RESPECTS ARE
MUCH GREATER WITH TAIWAN.
THINKING ABOUT TAIWAN -- WE
COULD BE IN BIG TROUBLE
STRATEGICALLY OF CHINA DECIDES
TO TAKE A MOVE BASED ON WHAT
THEY SEE HAPPENING HERE IN
UKRAINE.
>> HILLARY CLINTON SPOKE ON
MSNBC THIS MORNING THIS MORNING.
SHE IS PRAISING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE.
>> FIRST, I WANT TO ASK YOU WHAT
YOU THINK ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S RESPONSE SO
FAR.
>> IT'S BEEN WELL EXECUTED THEY
ARE.
NO DOUBT THAT WE ARE NOT IN A
POSITION JUST A FEW YEARS AGO TO
RALLY ANYBODY, AND THEN BEGIN
IMPOSING SANCTIONS THAT WILL
RATCHET UP, AND THAT'S WHAT HE
SHOULD BE DOING.
>> I GUESS THE LITMUS TEST
TONIGHT, WE DID NOT SEE ANY
PEOPLE FALLING OUT OF AIRPLANES
ON THE WAY OUT OF THE UKRAINIAN
AIRFIELD.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
UNDERGROUND AND SUBWAYS IN
UKRAINE, AND LORD KNOWS HOW MANY
HAVE ALREADY LOST THEIR LIVES.
>> THEY ARE TAKING CREDIT FOR
THE SANCTIONS.
NOW, THEY --
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN HELPLESS IN THIS.
FINALLY, THEY'VE COME ALONG TO
IMPOSING SANCTIONS, BUT A LITTLE
LATE.
IT HAD NO DETERRENT EFFECT AT
THIS POINT.
NOW, THEY ARE JUST GOING